what is going on everyone it is axle
beats here for anime uproar and recently
we covered the 20 best net abilities of
hunter hunter and since you guys seem to
like that one so much today we're going
to be twisting that one a little bit and
discussing which characters in the
series best use their net abilities now
again just like last video this doesn't
particularly mean that the number one
character will not necessarily be the
strongest but at the same time being
strong doesn't really hurt the score
either if you enjoy this video and you
want to see more hunter hunter content
on the channel remember to leave a like
as well as a comment down below it only
takes a second but it really does help
with the youtube algorithm and of course
if you just haven't subscribed to anime
uproar yet what do you do and make this
the video that you subscribe and be sure
to click that bell to select all
notifications you can also follow anime
uproar on twitter and instagram at anime
uproar or you can follow myself at
excellionyt of course this video will
contain spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned unlike last
time i will obviously be allowing more
than one ability per character as we're
trying to look at things in a more
holistic view and just like last time
characters you might want to see here
but definitely will not include gon and
killua again gone's typical use of his
nen through john ken is just you know
kinda lame and not impressive like sure
it can quite literally pack a punch but
that's kind of it and yeah he has his
transformation but to me that's just not
practical enough to count that said it
is definitely more highly ranked on this
list than the last one as it served the
purpose of defeating an enemy who was
drastically stronger than him however
putting gone in a coma and taking his
ability to use nanoway in the future
just a little bit too drastic of a cost
for me meanwhile killua's godspeed gives
him a ton of speed and helps him react
by dodging and attacking automatically
the downside is that it totally drains
kilowatt very quickly but again as a
last resort this move could be great
until it leaves him wide open if you
need to escape or if he needs to deal
with a strong enemy this is a phenomenal
option but things that put the user out
after being used probably won't make it
onto the list as i just don't think
that's an efficient use of nen so i'm
hoping that these examples each help you
show how this list is going to work if
an end user can make use of their
ability even if it isn't great on its
own if it accomplishes a goal and has a
good sense of usability to it without
costing too much then it'll get a lot of
points with that said though let's get
into the actual list
so the first ones were a little bit of a
hard choice for me and it might surprise
you since i am putting them above gon
and killua especially since they're kind
of similar restrictions in play at least
in terms of when the abilities can be
used
but for number 20 and 19 we have the
choice between razer and komugi
razer was the final boss of greed island
who uses his 14 devils to play dodgeball
while komugi's rapidly evolving goongi
nen skill
well rapidly evolves her gungi skills
while these can be seen as extremely
specific skills which you could argue is
like gone's transformation there is no
drastic shortcoming and on top of that
they are perfectly fitting to the user's
lifestyles komugid lives to play gungi
and it was her skill in that game that
kept her alive with meruem at one point
she even says that if she lost her life
would be worthless
on the other hand razer is the de facto
guardian of greed island and more
specifically he's the gatekeeper for the
treasure and its completion players need
to pass through him to finish the game
for those who don't know razer prior to
being on greed island was a murderer on
death row and it was jing choosing to
hire him and develop his game that saved
him and gave him a new path and as such
using his ability to help guard the
ending of the game rather than using it
for violence like he might have when he
was younger shows how he has reformed
and is perfectly fitting for someone who
works in a game so for me i think number
20 would go to komugi while 19 goes to
razer just because of how razer's i
think has a bit more meaning and
character behind it in my opinion in
18th place we have what i believe is the
only person to share a spot on both
lists which is machi machi's nan allows
her to make threads which in itself is
fine but machi uses them for healing
through stitching wounds and even
reattaching limbs and offensively to
bind and control her opponents the
ingenuity to use something as simple as
making threads in such versatile and
useful ways is monumentally impressive
especially when both methods of use are
very useful for the phantom troop
allowing her to heal her allies to some
extent or to catch their targets if
crolo is the head of the spider then
machi is its webs
at 17 we have castro while this guy
might not have had the most relevant
role in the story as a whole his use of
nen was perfect for his position the
upper floors of heaven's arena are
filled with fighters using their men for
advantage and even without use of his
men castro was able to outdo just about
all of them with the exception of hisoka
whom he's just slightly weaker than when
it comes to hand-to-hand combat wing
even states that if castro had developed
his tiger bite fist he could have been
one of the strongest men users alive
however castro instead focused on his
double ability which made a clone of
himself having two of himself makes him
a deadly opponent and it's only with the
use of severe mind games that hisoka was
able to take him out even despite losing
an arm in the process however for using
an ability which was perfect for holding
the title in heaven's arena he
definitely gets the spot number 16 is
someone who didn't make it at all last
time but i think just makes the cut this
time and it's not just because she's a
waifu shizuku or as you might know her
vacuum girl in the phantom troupe is
able to summon a vacuum named blinky
that can suck up any non-living or
non-men substances this includes poisons
or gases from the bodies of living
people if you're trying to save a
teammate but more importantly this is
one of the greatest tools she has
specifically because of how it helps the
troop her vacuum is able to suck up the
crime scenes after they destroy a room
full of people leaving no traces of the
actions behind truly turning this troop
into something that feels like a phantom
more than anything this is just an
effective tool to help the phantom troop
in general which is kind of all she has
so it's a very good tool for her
character 15th place is another
character who didn't make it last time
but i think again just makes the cut
pito has a slew of abilities revolving
around her giant summoned spirit dr
blythe while many of the core abilities
are not exactly useful on the
battlefield they still do assist her in
her role of being one of meruem's royal
guards
at the end of the day if she can find a
way to use her nan in a fashion which
supports meruem that's good enough
the major way that she uses this is
similar to mochi's threads except on top
of the general control of a person's
body it also allows her to use that
person's speech and even their men which
you know if you're trying to conquer a
neighboring nation's castle then want to
control their king and give orders to
the nation is pretty useful beyond this
blyth can also be used to heal wounds
such as it did for komugi but it cannot
bring the dead back to life it can also
be used on herself to give her a massive
attack and speed boost
pito use her nan to further marilyn's
ambitions keep the most important person
in the world to him alive and to make
her more effective as a guard when it
came to combat all of this adds up to a
very easy addition onto this list
14 is what is said to be the ultimate
1v1 ability with hulkenberg's possession
arrow but hulkenberg uses his
subordinates aura to create both armor
and an arrow the arrow is possessed by
his subordinate spirit and flies at an
incredible speed that is nearly
impossible to dodge and on top of this
it can pierce any armor or nen ability
this is more than just a big offensive
and defensive boom though because more
importantly for the purpose of this
video it's that he uses his subordinates
to fuel this ability it's an ability
that only people in positions of power
like himself would be able to make
effective use of and for as long as he's
able to keep a supply of subordinates he
is basically unstoppable when it comes
to one-on-one combat which is pretty
damn effective thirteenth goes to bona
lenov what makes bonalenov's use of nen
so impressive is that it takes full
advantage of his body while normally
having a body full of holes might be
less than ideal bona lenov's battle
canterbile takes full advantage of those
holes wind blowing through them as he
moves or dances produces several
different effects his go-to is creating
some warrior garb and a spear which he
of course is very well trained in but he
can also summon a miniature
jupiter to crush whoever hears it and
honestly i can't really think of making
better use of the holes in his body than
summoning a planet to crush his
opponents
number 12 goes to benjamin his benjamin
baton allows him to inherit the net
abilities of his private army when the
original user dies
while this ability seems like it has
unlimited potential there are also
requirements of needing to wait until
the army member actually dies
so in reality it can be a bit slow i
actually had a bit of trouble deciding
where to put this one as it's pretty
similar to haukenberg's skill of using
his subordinates however the permanent
effects of gaining those abilities just
outweighs the temporary effect of armor
and arrows even if he does have to wait
until his wardens actually pass away
what i like about this specifically for
benjamin is that he was the first prince
of his nation and he's making the most
of his people while there is some
ethical questions in allowing his
subordinates to die for his own power
the idea of creating a lineage of
abilities is just pretty fitting for a
possible would-be emperor number 11
might seem a little bit strange given
how strong our last entry was but this
is another phantom troop member who is
well famously weak and that's where his
nen ability comes in shall narc rather
than fighting for himself is able to
place antenna on other people to gain
complete control over them this allows
him to make up for his own lack of
strength while also having the potential
to remove enemy threats
he can also put antenna on himself if
he's in a pinch which allows him to go
on autopilot essentially turning him
into a super saiyan for a short time
what i love about this is that schalnark
is able to make the best of his ability
to shore up his own weaknesses and more
importantly this allows him to be a very
valuable member to the phantom troop in
10th place we have nav nov's hide and
seek is one of the most subtle abilities
in the series but the way nav makes use
of it is perfection hide and seek allows
nav to create a pocket dimension with
multiple areas to store either people or
object which just in itself is very
useful add in the ability to create
multiple doors to each area in the real
world and you basically have a series of
secret tunnels
while this ability in itself is very
good knobs understanding of where and
when to use it are what make it very
powerful he makes full use of this
simple ability which even became the
linchpin behind the chimera ant invasion
arc and it just demonstrates how
talented he really is with it our number
nine is biscuit biscuit's magical spa
service is easily one of the best
support abilities in the series and that
is perfect for her biscuit's role is
often depicted as a mentor and as such
she uses her nan in a way which
facilitates the growth and development
of her students by summoning cookie she
can revitalize her students and heal
minor illnesses and diseases while also
making it so that they effectively don't
really need to sleep very much and can
continue to train for much much longer
periods with biscuit on your side you
can turn a week's worth of progress into
a month or more just based on the extra
time you have available and that doesn't
even take into account her healing your
muscles or injuries which all
supplements that as well
also while not super impactful in most
cases she can also make herself feel
young and cute despite being well not
those things but either way it is great
for her own personal morale so coming in
at number eight is one that people might
want a little bit higher but i think he
belongs here crollo the leader of the
phantom troupe is effectively useless on
his own but by stockpiling abilities
into his book with bandit secret he
gives himself a slew of powers and
options this ability is not simple to
use and the restrictions are crazy when
compared to something like meruem or
benjamin's abilities but the way which
chrollo actually uses this ability
despite these flaws speaks volumes and
yes that was a book pun it gets to the
point where crollo can even use multiple
net abilities at once and even
overpowered and killed hisoka which is
definitely worth something it isn't
enough just to have all of the abilities
you need to be able to make the most of
those abilities and krolo definitely
does that number seven is yupi who is a
mass of anger and power and for much of
his role in the story he can't really
control either however he eventually
gains his rage incarnate ability which
gives him full control
there isn't really much to be said about
this other than saying that yupi is
devastatingly strong and has learned to
master and harness that strength while
this might seem very high for just a
brute force user there's something to be
said about the need for brute force in
the existence of some characters and
yupi is one who makes that work as he's
a royal guard with that said i would
probably never put him any higher on
this list because it doesn't really
extend beyond that strength the only
real reason up even makes it this high
is because it isn't just the insanely
powerful abilities he has but because
he's learned to work with that despite
it appearing uncontrollable it's kind of
like saying that yes a nuke is very
powerful but being able to aim it is
probably more important than the power
itself
in sixth place we have the chimera ant
royal guard shayapoof the azerbab on its
own is a very useful and versatile
ability allowing pouf to break apart
into as many mini poofs as he'd like
however if the segments do get smaller
than a fly then he's no longer able to
see through them these are all still
controlled and very much a hive mind by
pouf and if they're destroyed by
physical force he can just reform them
on top of that more or less scouting
ability he can also add in his butterfly
scales which allows him to read the
person's emotions or physical state this
of course adds the information he can
attain he doesn't end his abilities
there though as he can manipulate his
own body to look like someone else or
even awaken other people's nan abilities
he can literally create and sustain an
army for meruem while acting as a scout
all of which makes him invaluable as a
guard our top 5 starts off with illumi
while his abilities do revolve around
needles which gross they have a ton of
different applications that illumi makes
the best use of for example disguising
himself as get a rocker hypnotizing
people brainwashing kilua to keep him
out of danger and in line and even using
corpses as his own army illumi takes the
base idea of needles manipulating the
things that they pierce and stretches it
to the absolute limits with creativity
and this allows him to be an extremely
powerful threat despite not being all
that special on his own i'm not saying
he's not strong but what i am saying is
that his strength is not why people fear
him so i know that i said that pure
power wasn't enough to make it on this
list but our number 4 has a reason for
this exception netero's bodhisattva on
the surface is the pinnacle of offensive
abilities however there is a devastating
downside to it as unless the user is
fast or dedicated enough to actually
make use of the attack patterns it is
nearly worthless
okay worthless might not be the right
word here for a giant buddha who has
insane power behind its attacks but it
is definitely less useful than compared
to when netero uses it netero's nen on
its own is fantastic but it's the way
that he's able to master such a complex
ability that really allows him to be so
high on this list years and years of
practice and dedication went into
attaining this and to me that counts it
was only because of netero's speed that
he was able to make use of the
bodhisattva and i think that this is
what this list is all about number three
this time goes to morel and his deep
purple when you think of smoke abilities
in anime you might jump to characters
like smoker from one piece maybe turning
into smoke intangibility or even
creating smoke but morel takes this use
of smoke and completely shifts the
dynamic he has the basic making smoke
thing but he can also shape it into
anything that he wants make them seem
living or even create up to 200 dolls to
fight for him he can shift their color
to make them camouflage or to make them
look real the versatility of this
ability is unheard of it basically
allows him to create literally whatever
he wants and on top of this his smoke
clouds and creations can be made nearly
indestructible if he wants them to be
which leads to him being able to even
lock him and his opponent in smoky jail
which is next to unescapable the use of
smoke in such diverse and creative ways
is well beyond what's expected of most
characters in the series even in a
system as unique as nen not all nun
abilities are created equal and morel
shows us that the same could be said for
nen users runner-up is kurapika whose
entire skill set revolves around hunting
down the phantom troop his dowsing chain
can lead him to objects where people
chain jail snares spiders and shuts off
their men holy chain can heal himself
judgment chain wraps around the target's
heart and forces them to follow an order
or instantly be killed steel chain will
steal then abilities and all of these
can be supplemented by emperor time
basically kurapika limited himself to
more or less only being able to use
these skills on the troop and as such he
developed an arsenal which makes full
use of his abilities and then even goes
beyond them all to perfectly enable him
to hunt down the phantom troop this is
the kind of deal that gone should have
been looking for rather than giving up
his men and going into a coma kurapika
makes full use of the limitation system
that nen has in place to gain the
biggest buff possible all to deal with
the troop which is all he really cares
about
it's the perfect example of how to use
nen to reach your goals however i don't
think that even this compares to our
number one hisoka hisoka is famous for
having one of the most simple abilities
in the series however purely based on
his own creativity it became one of the
most useful in the series as well as i
explained in the previous video bungie
gum which holds the power of both rubber
and gum can bounce back projectiles
sling objects act as a bungee to draw
enemies or repel himself glue himself to
the ground to gain leverage pull back
weapons that he has thrown stop his own
bleeding temporarily reattach missing
limbs bring himself back to life by
resuscitating his heart and lungs launch
himself forward and so much more and
that doesn't even bring into account
texture surprise which we saw him using
to fool castro into thinking he didn't
lose an arm to fool the phantom troop
into thinking that he was a member and
to alter his prophecy from crollo and so
many more things throughout the series
the pure variety and ingenuity of hisoka
throughout the entire series made him an
easy number one for me in this video and
there you have it my opinion on what the
20 best nen users throughout hunter
hunter are obviously this is a pretty
subjective list but if you think that
there are some characters who should
have been higher or lower or others who
just should have made the list in
general be sure to let me know down in
the comments if you guys enjoyed this
hunter hunter video and want to see more
please leave a like and if you're new to
anime upper remember to subscribe and
ring that bell by selecting all
notifications you can help guarantee
that you will not miss any future videos
and of course you can follow anime
uproar anime upper on twitter and
instagram or you can follow myself at
excellionyt i want to give a big thank
you to all of our patrons over on
patreon who allow videos like this to be
possible especially the patron of legend
the one who's acknowledged by lord twego
himself alpha sigma as well are the one
tier patrons the ones who stand above
all clans in grata patahepha al-jatal
hinokami and water the toasted chi the
spike 8227 corey mcgowan dylan isadore
spidey life tinnell tungsten tarkis
baked buddhist cody hebert and monkey d
quilly finally our pro hero tier patrons
gilgamesh the red haired raven anel cruz
rathwind de ora very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks joanne garcia ted noted fat
boy games and soul rise slice and dice
if you enjoy our work or maybe think we
just offer a little bit of extra
enjoyment in your day-to-day life please
consider going to patreon.com anime
uproar and supporting the channel for as
little as one dollar you will get your
name featured in future videos as well
as have access to our exclusive patron
only discord you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe option
but whichever way you support us you
will get these same great benefits thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time stay excellent
[Music]
you